oh hello I don't know why I did that I
want to make it look kind of like a
cheesy 80s intro so anyhow comic-con
also dropped a trailer for Aquaman I'm
totally not wearing an Aquaman shirt I
don't own an Aquaman Church story of
Aquaman is Arthur curry who is Aquaman
his mother was the queen of Atlantis his
father was a lighthouse keeper hey kid
Arthur curry who is Aquaman one could
argue rightful king of Atlantis that's
up for debate among Atlanteans and his
half-brother arm
otherwise known as ocean master he hates
human beings who he's like I'm gonna go
ahead and wipe out those landlubbers
again very much looks like Geoff Johns
Aquaman so it looks like we have the
adaptation of Geoff Johns Shazam and
also Geoff Johns Aquaman hopefully I
remember all the villains on this one
that I've read yeah captain one-eye who
sees magic was also in the Jeff Jones
Shazam arc that I read would Black Adam
showed up completely eclipsed the guys
don't know who captain egghead is though
but he looks cool just kidding this
[ __ ] black manta know who he is they
did make black man to look pretty bad as
I was happy about that
I had always seen black mantas helmet is
looking kind of dorky now I see some
stuff as of late where I'm like it's
actually the opposite of dorky that's
cool it can be intimidating maybe even
scary like if I saw that coming at me
down a hallway or in the dark of water
I'd [ __ ] my pants but if they really do
play a black man to story it lends
itself to this being one of those
perception is reality maybe we can kind
of empathize with the villain kind of
because you know he's gonna do some dick
stuff I hope they go that route so it
does look like arm is declaring war
Atlantis is declaring war against human
beings Arthur Currie Aquaman needs to
stop it but in order to do that he has
to step up his king of Atlantis which
means challenging his brother which kind
of makes this plot akin to black panther
kind of at least the second half of
black panther exploiters for black
panther when his good guy has to step up
and fight bad King for the sake of
taking the throne and maintaining peace
holy [ __ ] that is the Lion King a lot of
CGI in those trailers true I suppose
when Atlantis is declaring war on the
mainland you're gonna have a lot of
tidal waves a lot of destruction a lot
of CGI also down there in Atlantis a lot
of CGI Atlantis looks like a great place
the wonderful but it just looks like
another world and that's what the ocean
really is there is another world on this
world it's called the bottom of the
oceans a lot of neat stuff to see I've
never seen any of it went snorkeling
once that was fun so I'm glad it has
that otherworldly appeal it looks like
they're incorporating those things from
the abit I can't think of they're in the
hair in Aquaman they're in the comic
books can't think of their names
at all there's a difference between
enjoying something and knowing every
facet of information about that
something there is something that
bothers me I don't know why it bothers
me am I alone in this bothering me when
they're underwater there's no real
indication that they're underwater I
mean their hair it looks like they're
underwater sure they're doing the little
mermaid hair aerial thing fantastic but
when they speak there are no bubbles
that come out but you can also hear them
perfectly nothing sounds muffled there
are no bubbles or no waves like they're
talking those worst pep talk ever
and I imagine they'll explain it in the
movie and I imagine I'll get used to it
when I'm watching it as I perceive it
and assess the information right now ah
keep in mind this isn't a huge crime
it's just an observation just say the
story interest me it's a guy who's from
a world who doesn't want to step up to
be the king of that world and like as
said in the trailer is exactly why you
are which we've heard a hundred times
before and a hundred movies before comic
book and otherwise what is a recurring
theme because it's a powerful thing but
unpopular opinion if I had to choose one
I like this Shazam trailer better
because this looks bigger but Shazam
just it looks like more fun to me but I
guess I'm an optimist on the DC Universe
which is now the worlds of DC which is
actually pretty smart thing to do you
don't want to wipe out the DC Cinematic
Universe completely but you want to
incorporate other things just make it
different universes that aren't really
linked may sound confusing at first but
that's what comic books do and I'm sure
the first-time comic books did that
readers were confused and they adapted
because people are adaptable and they
moved on movie goers they will adapt and
move on or is it the Aquaman trailer
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]